&gt;&gt; 0. That is the number that we're looking for. Now, we think about either a or
b or really any real number. There are three options in terms of their value.
They can either be positive, they can be negative, or they could be neither
positive nor negative, in other words, 0. Now if we multiply two positive things
together, we get a positive number. So a and b can't both be positive or else we
wouldn't get zero. Two negative numbers multiplied together also gives us a
positive number. So a and b can't both be negative either. A positive number
times a negative number, or, the reverse order, a negative number times a
positive number, both equal negative numbers. That's also not what we're looking
for. The only way to end up with a 0 as the product of two numbers is for one of
those two numbers that are being multiplied together to equal 0 itself. So
either a or b or both a and b must equal 0.